[Music]
heather is with us in richmond virginia
hi heather welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and christina thanks so much for
taking my call today absolutely how can
we help
um so i uh
paid my i had student loans starting
from 2012 and i have been actively
paying
exactly as i should never went into
deferment
paid all the way through the pandemic
and then decided to make a lump sum to
pay off um pay them completely off in
january of 2021. wonderful i recently
found
yesterday
but i recently found out that i would
qualify for um that i really likely
would qualify for the ride in student
loan forgiveness
and i'm wondering if there should be any
moral dilemmas or
misgivings about this um because i don't
you know i don't need this money i'm on
baby steps four five and six and so
should i have any misgivings about
possibly applying for this forgiveness
um
i don't know if i'm allowed to tell you
what your morals are
um uh
so i i can tell you where
um
okay so kind of let's talk about a
couple of metaphors all right to kind of
walk alongside this on ethics a lot of
ethics things are if you if you answer
them uh and say
how would i want to be treated if i were
on the other side of this if you're on
the other side of something from another
party then you can look at that that's a
little difficult here because this is
the government you're on the other side
of so
it's kind of like it gives a rip on that
part of it but like you know we tell
people not to use credit cards we're
just talking about that and then we have
sometimes a business owner who's gone
through financial peace university paid
off a bunch of credit cards gotten rid
of all their credit cards only has debit
cards
and they hate credit cards and they own
a pizza restaurant
now do i is it a moral dilemma for them
to take a credit card
i tell them it's not a moral dilemma for
them to take a credit card
uh because they don't i'm a public
figure i come out tell people don't use
credit cards so for me to use a credit
card would be pretty much straight up
hypocrisy right
i came out and the state of tennessee
passed uh this ridiculous lotto a few
years ago and i knew the data on the
lotto before they passed it the data on
lottos if you guys out there don't know
is um
the state of tennessee uses a lot of
money to send people to college okay you
get three four thousand dollars five
thousand dollars or whatever if you live
in the state of tennessee towards your
college from the lotto fund however the
lotto is primarily pa played by people
in poor zip codes so it's pretty much
poor people sending rich people middle
class people to school
and so i i raised hell about that when
they're passing in the state of
tennessee i lost the state passed it
it's been going for a decade or more and
when my kids went to college you know
they qualify for it's not income based
at all
everybody can get the 3 000 bucks so do
i go get the 3 000 bucks no
i'm a public figure that campaigned
against it for me to go take that money
then
would be
hypocritical
but heather on the other hand you're
more like the pizza store owner
you haven't publicly come out and
decried on the front page of the wall
street journal that this whole thing is
a scam and a bunch of freaking
communists running dc you know you know
like i have right and so you're not in
the same position of the ramsey
personalities
any ramsey personality to take student
loan forgiveness as hard as we've come
out against it would be inconsistent
but but you know
if our
young lady 25 years old is a creative
and works somewhere inside of ramsay is
she morally wrong to take the
forgiveness no it's a government program
she didn't steal anything she didn't do
anything wrong it's not uh she's not
being a nerdy well so i don't think you
have a moral
uh thing i also am okay if you decide
you don't want to take it on moral
grounds
either one would be fine with me is what
i'm trying to say i don't know you got a
lot of thoughts about this yeah i've
talked to a lot of people the last
several weeks i've done a lot of
facebook and instagram lives hearing
people's opinions and it's just all over
the place a lot of people are really
upset about it a lot of people are super
excited about it and there's just the
whole whole range of emotions and i
think it's hard because i i actually put
a pull out on my instagram to see you
know how people felt and about 80
percent of the people that responded had
negative reactions they weren't happy
about the forgiveness and and all of
that so i could understand if maybe your
friends are frustrated about the
forgiveness that you're probably a
little bit hesitant um and i also i
think it's okay to say hey you know i
don't know that washington
should have made this decision maybe you
disagree with the decision and also
still go but the decision's been made
and i'm going to go ahead and get the
forgiveness like i think like dave said
it really just depends on your own
morals and what you decide but i think
you can feel multiple emotions at the
same time
be frustrated if you want to be
frustrated about this isn't decision but
also realize the decision's been made um
possibly obviously there's still some
loopholes that have to be gone through
we'll see we'll see but but also still
get the forgiveness i don't think it's
really you know bad if you end up
getting getting some of that money back
yeah and you know i guess another
metaphor and this is probably a little
bit harsh of a metaphor but you know
a lady called in one time that was a
single mom who had lost her job and had
two little kids
and um
you know she said i i'm morally opposed
to welfare but i need to take it to feed
my kids right now and i said well are
you going to take it as a way of life
for the next 50 years no just so i can
find something to work to do and i said
honey that's what welfare is for
go get your kids some food
as a taxpayer that's paying for that i'm
i'm okay with that now do i want to
finance you doing that the rest of your
life no that's not good for you it
steals your dignity
but but i'm not i'm not saying you're
some kind of uh horrible deadbeat single
mom feeding your kid with a welfare
check i mean right uh you know until you
get until you're able to land a job yeah
and so that's the same kind of thing
this is probably that's probably even
more visceral or harsh than this
discussion but um so yeah i i i i i'm
going to be your friend either way
heather is what i'm saying it doesn't
bother me but i think that people would
judge me
harshly were i to take that or my family
were to take that after i've taken a
public person's stand on it and i think
that would be accurate to judge me that
way
because i think that'd be hypocritical
you see what i'm saying
yeah i um
i just was feeling a little conflicted
being that you know i i
on one hand i can think of a lot of ways
that i can you know i have a 529 for my
daughter that i could put that money
into
i'm adopting next year but then at the
same time i know that i don't need that
money when some so many other people do
that it's really important you're not
taking it from someone that that that
would have gotten it and if you weren't
around
like they're not going to go hey heather
got hers and we're out so joan you don't
get any because heather took it there's
not that's not how the program's going
to work okay so it's just going to be
now i will tell you one other thing to
think about and this is to thoroughly
not answer your question
is i the other thing i do sometimes
particularly when we're dealing with uh
things where i i think i'm i'm feel like
i'm right
on something but i'll just do it anyway
out of kindness or generosity
because and the rule i use on that is
when i'm 82 laying on my death bed am i
which way am i going to be happy i did
this
inside my heart of hearts in my soul am
i going to be happy i gave this a little
bit more
even though the server was horrible but
i left a little bit bigger tip i'm never
going to be mad at myself when i'm 82
laying on my deathbed doing that
but shorten them i might come up later
and go gosh i wish i'd been nicer you
know and so it when in doubt don't kind
of thing and that makes you further
conflicted but the the biggest concern i
got about the whole thing is you're
worried about it which kind of means you
shouldn't do it in a way that's what i'm
saying but but that's not a moral
blanket i would throw over everyone out
there listening to this conversation i
think we've made that clear but yeah um
yeah people are pissed and and
we can wrap it up with this i kinda
don't think it's gonna happen anyway
i really don't because they announced
this and they never told the department
of education anything about it before
they announced it and they never told uh
studentloan.gov and they never told you
know none of the website now the
administrative things there's 33 million
people they've got a process and they
didn't even tell the agencies that are
going to process before they announced
it it kind of makes me think they think
it's not going to happen man but if it
doesn't happen at this point it's going
to be a train wreck oh either direction
we'll see they'll blame it on the
republicans